as a lot of people continue to deal with
unemployment
wgu nevada is helping nevadans get their
college degrees
in high demand career fields here's more
hey rick welcome to las vegas now
thank you so much thanks for having me
really appreciate the time of course now
you guys are doing something really cool
at wgu you guys are
giving a new initiative or scholarship i
should say let's explain that
absolutely our mission overall is really
just uh
changing lives for the better by
creating pathways to opportunity
this new initiative which is called the
equitable access initiative
helps remove financial barriers from
prospective students
who are interested in continuing their
higher education endeavors
it's particularly aimed at those
students who are experiencing financial
hardship
such as job loss maybe changes in the
child care or family structure
due to health concerns uh and really
just the overall uncertainty that this
pandemic has caused
there's about six million dollars in
funding available
and i understand wgu has a
competency-based model what does that
mean
well the competency based model really
allows students to take advantage of
their knowledge and work experience
so that they can move quickly to
material they already know
so that they can focus their time and
energy on the things they still need yet
to
still need to learn now what are the
main parts of this act of this equitable
access initiative let's break it down a
little bit sure there's three components
we have the wgu resiliency grant
which assists new students again
experiencing unforeseen financial
struggles
offering them four thousand dollars that
can be used for tuition fees and
materials
again to allow them to pursue their
academic goals the deadline for this
grant has been extended to june 30th
uh the second component or the second
scholarship that we have is the wgu
opportunity grant
which supports new students who lack
access to federal or state financial aid
by offering them up to ten thousand
dollars a port over
applied over a four to six month four
six month terms
that can be used for tuition fees and
instructional materials
and at twenty five hundred dollars per
term the grant covers approximately
seventy percent of the total cost
of most degree degree programs for
students who graduate in two years or
less
and then lastly the online access
scholarship and what we have learned
through this pandemic is not everybody
is connected
not everybody has reliable broadband
access
and so this access scholarship really
provides those students with free
high-speed internet service
for the duration of their degree program
and it's not just limited to the student
in the household
but is also available for use for the
entire family in that household
bringing connectivity uh to those
underserved student populations for
whatever reason
you can't afford the high-speed internet
service or live in remote areas where
they just don't have the infrastructure
to connect to the internet wow that is
so great thank you so much for
everything you're doing for the
community and our students it's much
needed
now lastly you know how can people apply
sure they can just visit wgu.edu
and it's under the tab of scholarships
and financial aid
perfect you can call wgu nevada
at that phone number four seven
877-214-7000
zero five or visit their website wgu.edu
access we'll be